können sie irgendetwas positives sagen
die toiletten fall nicht gut wir sind
immer noch an der fritz hasenschule in
berlin und beschäftigen uns heute mit
dem hygiene konzept dazu treffen wir den
hygiene papst professor zastrow und der
erscheint wie es sich für einen papst
gehört immer dann wenn man nicht mit ihm
rechtlich
so liebe kinder herr professor zastrow
ja zunächst mal die frage sagen wir
professor zastrow oder der hygiene papst
wie sie wollen dann habe ihn der hygiene
hygiene papst dann sind wie ihre hygiene
messdiener heute wir haben mit den
lehrern gesprochen von dieser schule
hier und der endgültige hygieneplan ist
noch nicht da und nächste woche geht die
schule los da hätte man doch sage ich
mal ein bisschen zeit gehabt eigentlich
seit märz was zu entwickeln ja woran
liegt das wohl keine ahnung also meine
selbst märz muss ich jetzt nicht sagen
aber in den letzten acht wochen sind
keine neuen erkenntnisse mehr dazu
gekommen dass schwer verständlich warum
haben wir drei tage vorher das noch
nicht fertig ist ist erstaunlich eure
eminenz
es ist so wir zeigen ihnen jetzt die
schule wir haben alles getan
hygiene ist wichtig klar aber wir denken
sie die schule muss ja auch zu berlin
passen
im klassenzimmer spielt natürlich das
thema lüften eine zentrale rolle
nur leider stammt das schulgebäude aus
der ns-zeit und das sieht man an den
fenstern
viele lassen sich gar nicht mehr öffnen
können aber natürlich auch nicht saniert
werden aus denkmalschutzgründen und ich
dachte wir machen hier die mittel also
hier ist jetzt folgende situation also
während corona ist ja wichtig dass
gelüftet hat na ja und hier ist auch
alles okay also das fenster nicht das
ist jetzt nicht okay das kann man leider
nicht öffnen
aber die anderen kann man also wenn sie
mal hier gucken wenn das schon
vorbereitet also hier ist sogar im griff
dran ein fenster offen
ein sessel
völlig wirkungslos wir wollten ja immer
so eine art querlüftung jack wer geht ja
hier auch nicht aber auf jeden fall muss
man ja mit zugluft herstellen können
damit den populationen stattfindet und
auch ein luftaustausch
also wenn man jetzt nicht mal die
fenster offen hat dann staut sich das
hier alles auch wirkt aber auch nur sehr
schön wirkt aber auch nur wenn die
fenster offen sind dann ziehen der
praktisch oder drücken wir die
verbrauchte luft raus die ausgaben höher
drückt mir aus und frische luft kommt
rein wenn man das fenster einschlägt da
aber zwei müssen sie einschlafen sonst
haben wir gucken wir sind ja zwei ja
dann schlägt jeder ein fenster ein
abgenommen und weiter geht's los geht's
aber was gerade noch mal gerade nochmal
hat noch kein gericht das war knapp
also gerade im sportunterricht ist es ja
auch schwierig abstand zu halten
viele kinder laufen durcheinander da
haben wir uns jetzt auch nicht überlegt
und dann kann man da so und man hat
trotzdem den abstand gewahrt
[Musik]
also hier kommt der kreislauf in schwung
können sie mir helfen sind doch papst
will sich der nächstenliebe love dann
nicht anfassen deswegen und das schöne
ist ja auch sieht auch so ein bisschen
aus wie ein virus und die bisher jeder
ist sich selbst der nächste
die duschräume zastrow was sagen sie
sonst aus hygienischer sicht ja ich
würde wahrscheinlich den laden hier
dichtmachen
hier muss auf jeden fall mal erst
personen die man meinen letzten raum
sich rund 30
die methodik wir waren zu zweifeln wir
haben noch ein anderes hygiene konzept
kommen sie doch mal geradeaus ist uns
noch mal
sie dürfen sich alles angucken es wäre
nur wichtig dass sie vorher diese vr
was sagen sie schon wieder abgenommen
was halten sie davon dass jetzt jedes
bundesland auch das eigene hygiene
konzept entwickelt ja das ist total
bescheuert weil das virus verhält sich
überall gleich dass das ist ja eben
genau das schöne an der hygiene die
viren und bakterien machen überall auf
der welt alle menschen sind vor dem
virus gleich genau das ist ja genau das
ist jetzt ganz schön so schön das ist ja
auch eine predigt hier wir sind ja beim
hygiene jetzt kommen jetzt ein hygiene
konzept das haben nicht wir uns
einfallen lassen und das ist echt von
der schule ein hygiene konzept können
sich vorstellen haben sie eine ahnung
was das sein könnte das ist das hygiene
ein abgeschnittenes kabel für irgendeine
beleuchtung die nun nicht funktioniert
komplett falsch also es ist genial
es ist so darf er immer nur eine person
auf toilette
jeder schüler hat eine wäscheklammer
dabei jeder und wenn er auf klo geht
steckt er die wäscheklammer hier dran
und dann weiß der andere da ist jemand
drauf wie finden sie das
anregend für leute die gerne scherze
machen und ich am ende des tages 20
solcher klammern in der hosentasche
haben wir müssen mal reingucken ob das
überhaupt erforderlich ist nur ein
einziger
denn sie müssen ja hier ohnehin in
diesem bereich eine maske tragen fliegen
zuerst der papst hier könnt ihr jetzt
und
auf der verein und jetzt dass unsere
technische sperren
dann können die toiletten gewürzt werden
von fünf schülern zur gleichen zeit also
da mal übervorsichtig das zeigt auch
tatsächlich überfordert dann auch die
menschen sind mit diesen genen konzepten
die opfer sind
es ist einfach nicht nicht bedacht dann
bin ich wenn ich die massen habe brauche
ich auch den abstand nicht hier sind sie
doch weniger nicht dran als in der
u-bahn damit erstmal oder brüssel
das heißt der einzige bereich in dem wir
bei der nichts gemacht haben den fall
sie jetzt gut und haben sie abgenommen
und da sehen das haben sie sofort
gesehen mit ihrem gegebenes nachricht
anziehen muss man nichts mehr machen das
kann so eine super toll gelaufen
nochmal raus es ist ja trotzdem wichtig
auf abstand zu halten ja deswegen haben
wir hier folgendes konzept
diese ich sag mal käfighaltung dass
diese 150 auf jeden fall gewährleistet
sind was halten sie von dem konzept
finde ich sehr gut
ja wird ich würde das geht noch etwas
hört ihn damit ich nicht drüber kommen
kann ja okay also dass entweder noch
höher ziehen oder es gibt ein plan b
dass wir das mit so einer alleine machen
können dann würden sie kannst es gerade
mal übersehen könnten sie dafür sorgen
dass er sozusagen nicht zu weit raus
läuft wenn sie jetzt der lehrer wären
naja kommt hier aus dem käfig nicht aus
also ich bräuchte hier eine stange damit
ich ihnen bei weghalten ja die müsste
ein meter fünfzig das stange okay jetzt
stangen haltung finden wir auch besser
ich dann kann ich jede auf 1 meter 50
abstand halten
ja so dahin bis jetzt das fest es seien
ja und dann bleibt mir komplett also ein
ein meter fünfzig stange
dann brauchen wir das geht ja auch nicht
dass diese uhrzeit überhaupt gesendet
werden und dann unterbau sie auch keine
gnade schutzhüllen wir haben den abstand
denn sie ist bedenklich dass mich das
sexuell sehr anregt was ich hier sehe ja
da sollten sie mit ihrem psychologen
natürlich hatte mal drüber sprechen habe
ich schon her weiß das würde mich dann
auch bedingt ich denke sie an wenn ich
die antwort ja so dann würde ich sagen
gehen wir weiter und ich fände es gut
wenn du ab jetzt noch größeren abstand
zu mir ja
eure eminenz wie fanden sie das hygiene
konzept ist die schule fit ich muss
ehrlich sagen familie kommt häufig gar
nicht erkennen können also sie würden
jetzt als als sie gene papst uns jetzt
nicht das gros geben und sagen
willkommen kinder los geht's nein also
ein regiekonzept gegen korona kann ich
überhaupt nicht erkennen
gar nicht und für und damit wirst du
eigentlich erledigt das heißt wird sagen
wir segnen die schule noch ein bisschen
mit desinfektions wasser und dann hoffen
wir das beste
und dann hoffen wir dass es länger als
eine halbe stunde hält
[Musik]
hallo ich hatte gar nicht bemerkt ja ich
sitze hier gerade noch an der recherche
für die neueste ausgabe der heute show
ihr könnt ja so lange schon mal den
kanal abonnieren und euch das ganze zdf
spezial in der mediathek angucken ich
mache so lange weiter
fabian bisher mit der recherche langsam
fertig und bringen mir ein cocktail aber
mit schirmchen